you help with osteoarthritis paid in hands and back. So osteoarthritis, there's two different types
of arthritis. There's degenerative arthritis and there's inflammatory arthritis. Not to say
that degenerative arthritis can't be inflammatory, but it is to say that those two classifications
of arthritis exist. And typically the inflammatory arthritis tend to be autoimmune like rheumatoid,
psoriatic arthritis and gaudy arthritis are fall into the inflammatory arthritis category.
Degenerative arthritis or osteoarthritis or degenerative joint disease or degenerative
dysd disease all are in the degenerative arthritis category. So degenerative arthritis is
and osteoarthritis, all those are all the same building clutches. So degenerative arthritis
has to do with like wear and tear of a joint. So degenerative arthritis would be common in
I hurt my knee when I played football in high school. Now at 40 years old my knee has been
acted up and it just gets swollen at different times if I aggravated or you know I hurt my hands
doing physical work my whole life and whatever job I did and now I get inflammation in my
fingers and joints. And the way the difference in diagnosis has to do with looking at whether you
have antibodies of person has rheumatoid antibodies they would fall into the inflammatory arthritis
category and you treat that very different than you would a degenerative arthritis or osteoarthritis.
So if it's osteoarthritis you'll see an x-ray it will look differently too you'll have
it will just look different on a playing field x-ray it'll look different on a CT scan and MRI as well.
So what do you do with the degenerative joint disease with the degenerative arthritis that's causing
pain? Well it still is inflammatory in the sense that every time you aggravate it you have inflammation
there and that's really what's causing the pain. So you could use anti-inflammatories like flavonoids
so like curcumin as well stinging nettle, resveratrol, green t-extract those kinds of things would
be good for the inflammation. The other thing that's good if it's a degenerative joint disease
or osteoarthritis is chodroitin and glucosamine so especially if it's a larger joint like your
even your fingers can help with that and certainly shoulders for your hip joint because your
joints are tolds that come to there that there's for my joint castle and in that joint castle is a fluid
and that joint fluid is produced by the joint capsule cells and glucosamine and chodroitin helps
stimulate production of that joint fluid. So the more fluid you have in there the more cushion you have
of the joint and the less irritation it's going to be. So glucosamine and chodroitin typically their
sulfite can be beneficial taken for those and using topical anti-inflammatories can be helpful.
Using ice can be helpful. Using ornica can be helpful. Using CBD products can be helpful. So all
those things can be helpful. If it is osteoarthritis being careful of functioned how you're using it
maybe you're walking incorrectly if it's a knee problem getting some support, some orthotics support
for your feet can be helpful. Going to a car partner can be helpful. Getting physical therapy can
be helpful. All those things can be helpful for osteoarthritis. If it isn't inflammatory arthritis
and if it is an autoimmune condition connection do it now that's a whole different ball of wax
that we're talking about. Still you could be helped with the flavonoids and the anti-inflammatory
things but you need to dig in to find out what the triggers are. If it's rheumatoid arthritis
typically foods that are considered in the category of lectins that is like potatoes and
peppers and tomatoes in that category tend to in general cause more inflammation with rheumatoid
arthritis patients but there can be other food issues that can cause inflammation. So you have to
really yeah if you think there's an autoimmune connection you got to dig into the triggers for that
like I talked about in that mother question. Going and joining our autoimmune course would be highly
recommended. It's super cheap right now so go to cuttersclinic.com and you can click on the courses.
The autoimmune chronic disease and autoimmune course if you have any suspicion that it is like a
rheumatoid or something like that.